well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Tuesday April the 9th
2019 session in our series about
entrepreneurship and Asian high-tech
industries
I'm Richard Dasher I direct the u.s.
Asia Technology Management Center we're
very proud to be presenting this series
in our 26th year of presenting these
kinds of public seminars at Stanford I
would like to point out that the US Asia
Center is a membership based industry
affiliates organization and so all of
our support comes from member companies
we have 5 member companies right now
about to be seven as soon as we get the
next checks in and so we hope that
you'll get to meet the representatives
of our companies some of whom are here
today and we'll have some refreshments
outside thanks to their support and
please stay around and get to know each
other and talk more about the session
and do some Silicon Valley style
networking so I'm happy to be able to
present what's really a yearly talk I
give this Asia entrepreneurship update
every year as part of the series usually
I give it in the first week but last
week as you know I was in Tokyo with Tim
Romero who talked about the situation in
Japan that should be up on video soon if
it is not already so make sure you try
to find the type of that session if you
were not here in person yeah this is
going to be a weekly series will run
through May the 28th this year you can
always find out more information on our
website and what we're really trying to
do is to bring information and insights
about entrepreneurship and the
supporting ecosystems around the major
major economies of East Asia this is
available for credit to Stanford
students but everyone is welcome if
you're taking the course for credit make
sure
you get a copy of the syllabus because
the requirements for this seminar a
little bit unusual I asked each student
to give me a weekly comment and I
usually reply directly to that weekly
comment so it gives me a chance to
interact personally with every person
that's taking the class but that's a
little different from the way a lot of
seminars here work so be careful anyway
where do you get started when you're
talking about Asia money's a good place
so the total size of the world economy
world gross domestic product in 2018 was
estimated to be about 134 trillion
dollars and the largest single country
economy in the world is China the US
comes in at number two notice that there
are four Asia countries in the top ten
largest economies in the world and there
are now nine Asia countries that are all
in what's called the trillion dollar
Club now this is calculated at purchase
power parity if you use the real
exchange rate you can get in a bank the
numbers would be very different this is
calculated on what you can buy with a
particular amount of money or what how
much money it takes to buy a particular
basket of goods but it's a very good way
to compare economies to see what you can
actually do from one to the next now one
reason Asia is so interesting is because
of graphs like this this is the gross
domestic product of China this is the
gross domestic product of the US was
really about 2014 when China became the
world's single largest economy notice
that India is doing very well India is
also growing at a rapid rate and Japan
and Germany kind of round out the top
five countries in the world with what
you would call slow and steady
I think the Japanese don't like it very
much I haven't heard too much
complaining about growth rates from the
Germans even though they're down around
you know 0.9 percent usually the Tigers
these used to be the jumping-off places
to China the main reason to show this
and so you get a sense of the relative
size South Korea is the biggest one in
terms of the size of its economy and
then right after that you have Taiwan
and you have Singapore and South Korea
and Hong Kong Special Administrative
Region what most people are really not
expecting is the next slide in
developing Asia if you look at the same
kind of growth pattern look at Indonesia
people have really been missing the huge
amount of economic power that has been
created in Indonesia over the years it's
the largest population of any of the
Southeast Asian countries and it's by
far the largest economy now so when you
have that kind of thing going on people
are always interested in what's coming
ahead and one of the big sort of things
that people tend to look at more than
these absolute numbers is the percentage
of growth every year that an economy is
experiencing if you look at that and
unfortunately they don't do that in PPP
so this is in real GDP calculations you
see that the growth rate in China has
slowed down considerably you see a wide
variation in what's going on in India
and you see this kind of you know the
world is cruising along at three point
seven percent for the last four years or
the last two years and it predicted to
stay about the same rate and yet all of
these major economies from Asia are
growing a lot faster
even as China slows it was about 10% a
year in as recently as 2014 or so 2012
down to what is predictably
6.2 percent this year 6.2 percent in an
economy the size of China in absolute
terms is a much bigger amount of
economic output than you get with a much
higher growth rate in a smaller economy
so this is one thing why China is still
interesting to people even though it
slowed down but I think it's noticeable
worth noting that the Chinese government
is definitely taking actions that I see
as if not in response to they are
correlating with this slowdown there
especially worried about the big
infrastructure industries that really
grew up in the last generation in China
consumer spending became the main driver
of the Chinese economy about seven or
eight years ago but what happened all
the infrastructure companies well we
have 150 billion dollars invested by the
Chinese government in the belt and Road
initiative so that this will actually
help those companies to expand to global
markets as their own domestic market
slows down we have a lot of
international investment going on by
private sector Chinese firms we'll talk
some more about that later in the
economy but I think rather than being
something about innovation or
entrepreneurship that's global expansion
this is a companies that are truly
becoming multinational corporations and
that's a new thing for China we've seen
it in you know the Japanese and Korean
companies for the last you know
somewhere between 50 and 20 years but to
really have multinational companies in
China is kind of a new thing now as an
economy slows down though you expect
more protectionism and China has not
opened up yet the Chinese market is very
difficult for a lot of foreign firms to
get into you can't see facebook in China
this will be put on YouTube but you will
not see this on YouTube in China unless
you use some sort of a dodgy you know
VPN that you might get in trouble for
and so there's a lot of things that are
unresolved about China I'm not going to
get into that too much today but it's a
real wild card we really don't know how
it's going to play out one thing you can
see is that the patterns of growth that
are leading to these high economic
growth patterns really reflect the new
spending patterns of an emerging middle
class and this is characteristic not
only in China its characteristic
especially in Southeast Asia now I was
in Thailand a couple of weeks ago and it
was fascinating to see luxury items
right next to things that you wouldn't
expect any other way we met the head of
line corporations subsidiary in Thailand
and he pointed out that something like
two thirds of the 45 million people who
have line accounts there are paying
their cellphones off every day they're
buying minutes every day and he says if
you try to have a subscription-based
service here it won't work so you know
there's a lot of things to think about
how things are developing in these
different countries India GDP growth is
noticeable but I'm seeing a polarization
of India into really two different
systems you've got the world class
information technology service providers
most of whom are making most of their
money outside of India and you've got
the domestic economy where you have a
lot of what's called frugal innovation
you have a lot of things that are really
developing for the early stages of
and a developing economy increasingly
this ecosystem in Asia is separate and
distinct from the rest of what we're
used to
it's not something with the United
States as a hub anymore there are new
supply chains that are servicing these
new Asia consumer markets and you know
in the middle of this China is really
intentionally developing
self-sufficiency across the board not
only is it investing in artificial
intelligence but it's also investing a
lot in the very basic components
computer chips and it's developing at
the other end new kinds of automobiles
and they even actually be ahead of
Western countries and autonomous driven
vehicles in a few years so you know
Southeast Asia is no longer just the
beginning stages of a supply chain that
ends up in the US or Japan or Europe
you're seeing an awful lot of
cross-border expansion inside Asia after
the u.s. pulled out of the trans-pacific
partnership it's been kept on as TPP
minus one and China has it's competing
version of this free trade agreement
called the RCEP
and you're also seeing the private
sector taking of doing a lot of things
to expand across the region grab I
mentioned line visiting their Thailand
offices
go jack lazada these are our companies
that have successfully become
multinational at least six or seven
different countries a lot in Southeast
Asia so there's a lot of investment
going on cross-border inside Asia you're
seeing unicorn creation across Asia I'll
talk a little bit more about that in the
innovation section of the talk today
and Southeast Asia is the new
battleground for influence you see it on
both sides the Chinese government is
using this belt and road initiative it's
a way to project soft power and it's a
way to help its own domestic industries
and it's a way to fulfill what it sees
as its appropriate place in the world
order right now and you know a lot of
the expansion going on by companies like
Alibaba and 10 cent are to reduce the
influence of companies like Amazon in
other parts of the world so uber had to
sell it Southeast Asia business to grab
but it did get some grab stock in there
as a result so it's not like it
completely lost out of the deal Alibaba
has bought 83 percent of the Singapore
based electronic commerce company lazada
that's in half a dozen different
countries and it has also invested over
a billion dollars in tokopedia which was
a competitor to lazada that's based in
Indonesia Expedia has led group kind of
investment in tokopedia which is a
travel site kind of like travel loca I'm
sorry not tokopedia travel oka which is
a travel site kind of like Expedia is
itself and Amazon started its prime
services in Singapore now in the middle
of this you're seeing a lot of books
about New World Order Kai Fuli just
wrote one about AI superpowers and he
points out that it's a different type of
expansion being done by American firms
that are done by the Chinese firms the
Chinese firms tend to look for more
local partners and tend to work really
through their local partners more while
the American firms tend to just export
their services over to the other country
a lot of people in China thing
but their approach will be more
successful one because there's a lot of
similarities in the purchasing behavior
in the consumer behavior of this
emerging middle class in these different
countries and it's rather different from
the old-style middle class that you have
in the old advanced economies so another
thing that I think is going on in
general in Asia right now is that
attention to social concerns is actually
being turned from a problem into a huge
opportunity area so especially in Japan
and almost that much in South Korea and
almost that much in China people are
really worried about the aging
population so guess what there are
hundreds of new companies that are being
created around you know things to make
the situation better for people as they
get older you're seeing a lot of
leapfrogging
going on where even though the
infrastructure that we have in advanced
economies has not been developed they
will allow people in these emerging
economies to have the same kind of
services using their cell phone so
mobile banking is probably is a lot
further ahead in that part of the world
than it is here
and you know you're seeing a lot of
attention being paid to the UN's
sustainable development goals I can't
tell you how many executives I run into
Japan who have a little SDG lapel pin
that they're wearing now another kind of
driver is the shift to the digital
economy so even though you would think
that there are not enough people who
know how to do AI programming or other
kinds of software programming that would
be a huge mistake people are very quick
to learn and you're seeing serious
technology plays coming out of places
all across
Asia but there is still a lot of
variation in the Asian economies and to
understand the dynamics of what people
see as their competitive advantage it's
worth looking at what the World Economic
Forum calls the three stages of Economic
Development so what we used to talk
about is early stage developing
economies they call factor driven
economies typically in a factor driven
economy the per person GDP or income sum
whatever I mean the some people want to
count income some people want to count
GDP but it's below fifteen thousand
dollars a year and in that kind of a
sitting this is this is the situation
where you're getting the first
industrialization of the country
socially people start to flock to the
cities hundreds of millions of people
have moved into the cities in China over
the last twenty five years and that this
is not stopping this means that the
business opportunities are everywhere so
why do you take the trouble to develop
an advanced technology if you can make
money with a simpler play this is why
people have kind of downplayed Chinese
technology capabilities for too long the
business opportunities don't require it
and so you know why take the extra risk
getting there first to the market is by
far a much more important competitive
advantage the government role at this
stage is really basic laws commercial
code proper ship you know bankruptcy all
of this kind of stuff happens in this
stage the second stage is usually called
efficiency driven the first companies
that have become successful during the
first stage need to keep growing and you
will often have labour and capital
shortages as a result
and so they tend to grow by
globalization they will grow the
domestic markets as much as they can and
then they'll take the same thing and go
overseas we're seeing that in China now
we saw it in Korea in the early nineteen
ninety nineteen 90s we saw it in Japan
from late 1970s so this is a kind of
thing that is a natural part of economic
development which means that the
opportunities are scaling up great
quality operational efficiency and it's
really at this stage that governments
get real serious about intellectual
property rights as long as foreigners
own all the intellectual property no
country is really going to care about it
that much but when you have domestic
people who are having problems with
intellectual property infringement
people get real serious real quick the
number of patent infringement cases in
China is exploding and interestingly
enough the foreigners who are bringing
court cases in China now actually have a
slightly better success ratio than do
Chinese domestic companies maybe because
they're used to fighting that fight but
in any case this is characteristic of
the middle income level the middle kind
of stage of economic growth this can be
a very dangerous stage it's been very
dangerous in Japan and in South Korea
because it's been hard to get out of and
I think one reason is that you learn how
to be successful globalizing your
company expanding your company with
great quality with scaling up all of
those kinds of things require refining
your business processes and being even
more strict in how you maintain them
unfortunately for the next stage what
really matters is distinguishing
yourself by having exactly right thing
for the market even before the market
knows it wants it this is the innovation
driven stay
the economy and companies kind of have
to unlearn some of the things that they
learned during the second stage so
wealth spreads throughout the population
parents don't really want their kids to
grow up and become line workers in a
factory even though one of the problems
for economic structure is that at the
second stage of an economy there are a
lot of really well-paying jobs that
don't require more than a high school
education but people always give their
kids a college education and so the kids
don't really want to deal with the old
type of economy either at this stage the
real competitive advantages have to do
with understanding risk and being able
to accommodate risk not avoid it but be
able to deal with it in a very efficient
way how to keep how to keep high growth
going so you know if you're a startup
company that wants to change the world
and you have changed the world and
become a big company how do you keep up
that high rate of growth so that's what
happens in the innovation driven stage
and it's at this stage that the
government starts to really worry about
its startup sector of the economy we've
seen that here in the early 1980s with
SBIR grants you're seeing it now with
similar kinds of programs in lots of
Asian economies so if you look at what's
going around at some of these Asian
economies per person GDP in China right
now is about sixteen thousand eight
hundred dollars so it's clearly in the
middle stage it's in that efficiency
driven stage and sure enough you're
seeing the big Chinese companies
globalize you're seeing a huge rise in
venture capital and you're seeing
government support for R&D and really
national infrastructure development that
is looking ahead to the next stage I
will give this
crédit that it's very forward-looking to
try to develop this you know the
capacity to be an innovation driven
economy instead of just making the money
now and figuring it will happen later in
Japan it's an innovation driven economy
and you're seeing the startup ecosystem
grow we talked about that last week but
the big firms are still not able to
benefit from the system like they do
here just as a minor data point exits by
startup companies in the United States
that are backed by venture capital tend
to happen at a ten to one ratio ten
companies exit by being bought by big
firms for every one company that exits
by going IPO and so that's an indication
of how much the big companies are
getting or trying to get value from the
startup sector same kind of situation in
South Korea in fact I could really put
those two into one row of on this chart
with India the per person GDP is still
$7,100 that's a huge difference from
even what you see in places like
Indonesia now or other places and so you
do have these kind of two distinct
systems that are growing up alongside
each other some parts of India are very
advanced economy other parts of India
are very much you know
early-stage get their first kind of
factor driven economic development in
Singapore Singapore has a per person GDP
that's a lot higher than the US average
and is actually pretty close to the
Silicon Valley average Silicon Valley
incomes were somewhere around ninety
five thousand to a hundred ten thousand
depending on whether you live in San
Francisco or down on the peninsula last
year so Singapore is really close to
here and sure enough
the financing hub for that entire region
in Indonesia you've got an efficiency
driven economy that is the largest
domestic market in the region a lot of
infrastructure plays are still rolling
out and a lot of big company plays are
happening in Singapore Singapore is also
the location of four unicorns that were
created in the last ten years and and
Indonesia was the location of four more
there's also one unicorn in Vietnam and
one unicorn in one of the other
Southeast Asian countries sorry but in
any case you see that most of Southeast
Asia tends to be at that level and
that's the trigger level where you start
to see middle-class spending on things
like automobiles things like televisions
and so yeah this is why it's exciting to
a lot of people so let's get around to
entrepreneurship we've this was sort of
general economic discussion slanted
toward entrepreneurship but I want to
start out by talking about data that is
presented every year from a major
consortium called the Global
Entrepreneurship monitor they do a
survey of almost two hundred thousand
people worldwide every year now this is
run out of Babson College which is
famous for study of entrepreneurship but
they also have key partner universities
around the world and they use a local
team in each country to do the surveying
we're going to look at their adult
population survey which minimum size of
a good sample is 2,000 people and they
will not report the results for a year
if they don't like the way the data was
pulled so yeah
we're not going to use the second part
of the survey which is a survey of
experts asking them for they're really
kind of subjective opinions about the
ecosystem in that particular country
this is the 20th year that Jim has been
an operation and their online website is
a great place to go for data what I'm
going to focus on is what they call the
total early stage entrepreneurial
activity index also known as the T rate
and they've got a very clever definition
for this because as you know there are a
lot of really small businesses in any
economy that don't kind of fit the model
of startup we are talking about when
we're studying entrepreneurship so what
they do is in this tr-8 they include
people who are actively involved in
setting up a business or people who are
managing a new business that have paid
salaries for up to three and a half
years once you've paid salaries for more
than three and a half years you fall out
of the tier 8 so if you look at how tea
rates tend to run we talked about those
three stages of an economy the tea rate
in general tends to drop as an economy
becomes more advanced one reason is
because in a developing economy there
are not as many salaried jobs in big
companies that people could have so more
people are entrepreneurs because they
have to be entrepreneurs
this is called necessity driven
entrepreneurship if you divide it up
between men and women it's interesting
that the tea rate actually jumps up a
little bit in the middle stage of the
economy if you separate men and women
out that's very counterintuitive but
if you look at what's going on you're
seeing that it's pretty close to the
sense of being necessity driven women
who are necessity driven they have to be
an entrepreneur in order to eat right
and it's not like they saw an
opportunity they want to seize there is
no job available to them that they could
take that's actually the greatest
participation is found at this middle
stage of economic development so that's
the general trend in tea rates and
economies the u.s. tea rate
sure enough shows what goes on in the
general economy it dropped like a rock
around the time of the last recession
and it's been going up steadily ever
since then so that we actually have a
higher T rate in the United States than
people do in China so if you look at
China the tea rates spiked in the year
2011 probably because of government
official announcements supporting
entrepreneurship and then it's kind of
been declining ever since then japan's
tea rate is very low and if you look at
India India has had a kind of gradually
may be declining tea rate it's kind of
hard to tell in general when you see a
lot of yearly variation it means that
the economy is in some sort of a state
of change means there's some sort of
flux going on and maybe structural
changes is in the way if you look at the
Tigers the jumping off places to China
you see consistently lower T rates than
the US right
I kept the UST rate in gray so it for
your reference but you see a gradual
sort of increase in the amount of
entrepreneurship in the economy that
reflects a shift in the
type of entrepreneurship that type of
motivation people have for
entrepreneurship in the early stages it
was driven by a necessity but in the
later stages of the more advanced stages
of an economy is because people see the
best opportunities they don't want to
just be earning a salary and not able to
exercise their creativity they see the
possibility of making the world
different and so you see this kind of
gradual increase over time since 2003
with Southeast Asia you start out where
everybody except Malaysia had a has a
higher T rate than the US that's not
surprising since they are in this early
middle stage of an economy right twelve
to sixteen thousand dollars a year of
GDP per person you see a lot of up and
down which to me says there's some sort
of change going on or possibly some sort
of a sensitivity to external factors
I didn't yeah I did put Thailand in here
so Thailand even didn't even count 2010
but they had terrible floods there then
and a lot of things really went down in
Thailand around the time of those floods
Malaysia was really depressed in a kind
of unusual way and I suspect it had to
do with non-economic factors I expect
that it had to do with concern about the
political system and just recently in
the last couple of years Malaysia has
been extremely active there's a group
called the Malaysia digital the economy
corporation which is kind of a third
sector public-private kind of thing they
have an office here in the US and they
bring groups of really interesting
Malaysian startup companies to investors
in Silicon Valley every year now
I think that given the amazing rise in
GDP it's sort of surprising that the tea
rates are gradually moving up instead of
dropping more noticeably I think the
China's slowdown maybe resulted one to
the slowdown in the economy and two to
the existence of more prestige jobs ba T
is starting to make it harder for people
to hire good people in start-up
companies Baidu Alibaba $0.10 and so
that has you know kind of is an
indication of major structural change in
progress in China there are some
attitudes that may shed a little bit
more light on this though first of all
the gem survey takes all the people that
did not fall into the tea category so
these are the thirteen percent of the US
population in 2017 it's 15 percent last
year who were actively engaged in
entrepreneurship of people who were not
in that engaged in that kind of activity
of the working population they asked
them what kind of opportunities do they
see for start-up companies around them
so sixty three and a half percent of
Americans saw good opportunities for
starting up a company around them
fifty-four percent of non entrepreneurs
saw or thought that they had the ability
to be a good entrepreneur we're very
confident when you see the numbers in
Asia realize that's very high percentage
thirty three percent of Americans were
not starting a company were not actively
engaged in entrepreneurship because they
were afraid of failing
sometimes that's real economic fear and
sometimes it's social fear but they're
afraid of failing
and the other thing that they asked is
do you intend to become an entrepreneur
to start a company in the next three
years so in the u.s. a few more people
14 and a half percent of the people they
polled said they were going to be an
entrepreneur and when you see this
number the intention number considerably
higher than the actual tea rate you can
sort of assume that the tea rate should
expand from that point so let's see what
happens
in the united states what has really
happened over the last 20 years is
everybody believes that opportunities
for entrepreneurs are just fantastic
most of these numbers are relatively
flat the actual tea rate the intention
to start a new company rate really
hasn't changed that much at all there is
a slight increase in the fear of failure
right so that that's a slight increase
there is pretty stable self-assessment
of our abilities to be an entrepreneur
we are very confident people but what
has really changed is that everybody
sees opportunities now well think about
it how many universities now have
training programs in entrepreneurship
right most of them started in the last
20 years so this is you know this is the
baseline now if you look at China you
see a very different kind of pattern
first of all I mentioned this bump in
2011 zoom everything went up not only
did the tea rate itself go up but the
intention to start a company skyrocketed
it also dropped like a rock within a
couple of years but the tea rate and the
intention to start a company rate has an
interesting gap of about 5% which means
that
there's going to continue to be robust
entrepreneur activities in the country
what I really see in this graph I'm sure
enough there was a year or two when they
wouldn't take the data they didn't like
the sample that they got from China and
there is a lot of up and down but
gradually you see a kind of steady sense
of maybe slightly increasing
opportunities for entrepreneurs but not
a huge increase like we had in the
United States over that same period of
time in contrast what I'm seeing is a
steady decline in the fear of failure
and a pretty good strong sense of
perceived capabilities that steady all
the way across China
so it's a very entrepreneur friendly
environment people have attitudes that
yeah this is good but maybe fear of
failure is a little worse now because
people do have more money than they did
20 years ago that's not surprising if
you look at Thailand Thailand is
interesting because there is a huge gap
between the actual tea rate and the
intention to be an entrepreneur right
which may mean that a lot of people who
say they intend to start a company never
do and I think one reason they don't is
because Thailand has the highest fear of
failure rate we've seen well over 50
percent of the population is not
starting the company because they're
afraid of failing you see an increase in
the perceived opportunities maybe kind
of sort of is hard to tell because of
the gaps in the graph and you see not a
bad sense of their self-assessment of
their capabilities but what really has
happened is a super high fear of failure
right
and then you have Japan right so that
the base rate for entrepreneurship
people who know Japan are extremely
happy that it's gone up from about 1% to
almost 5% for the tea rate but look how
closely that tracks the intention to
start a company in the next three years
you're not going to see a whole lot of
change in this unless you start to see
that intention thing track up more to me
and of course the fear of failure is
high but it's not that high if you were
to compare this to Thailand Thailand had
a higher fear of failure rate than Japan
did and a much higher tier 8
the huge barrier in Japan is that people
do not see much good opportunities to
start the company and so that has to do
maybe with funding more likely it has to
do with how hard it is to get a product
to market if you're doing a consumer
play that's like an iPhone app it's not
that hard but if you're in the business
to business world it's extremely hard to
get a big company in Japan to give you
the time of day and so this is kind of
the situation of what's going on there
but I don't want to be too negative last
week Tim I thought gave a very well
thought-out description of what's going
on with the ecosystem around
entrepreneurship in Japan and I don't
really have anything to take away from
that but I want to kind of put it in
context of the whole region so if you're
looking at an innovation system
especially an entrepreneurial innovation
system you need to think about three
elements you need to think about people
you need to think about capital and you
need to think about ideas and knowledge
if you want to have a robust system of
Vernor you not only have to have
sources of those three elements you also
have to have dynamics that make it easy
to flow into a new combination now this
applies inside a big company as well as
in a startup company inside a big
company you've got to get a budget for
your R&D project you have to do
something with the intellectual property
that you create and you're going to get
the basis for that something from
somewhere so it does apply in a big
company too but it's really easy to see
inside a startup company inside a
startup company the people will start by
using their own capital they'll use
their own money to start the company off
and they will have to have the ability
to use their own knowledge or ideas if I
invent something at Stanford and it's
trying to start a company around it I
have to buy the rights to my technology
back from Stanford that means I need
capital and I also need to acquire the
right to use that knowledge in order to
run my company so different kinds of
things play into that model at the
different stages of company growth at
the startup one of the main things to
focus on in an entrepreneurship
ecosystem is the presence or absence of
angel investors mainly as a source of
money with regard to people you not only
have the founders but you have the
people who will mentor the founders
that's a very important part of this
system and in regard to ideas and
knowledge they need to have access to
are in the output Design Thinking is a
technique that people use to come up
with new ideas not only technology
knowledge but you also need market and
business knowledge you need to be able
to get that somehow if you don't already
have it and of course there's a need for
infrastructure both physical and for
structure and legal infrastructure and
also paid consultants who had never
really become part of your team but you
may need to know what somebody will say
about your market opportunity an order
to get money as the company gets started
and as the company is growing
that's when venture capital funds come
into play at the very late stages of
growth is where you get loans coming
into play the key things for people at
that stage are not the entrepreneurs
it's the people who are willing to go to
work in a startup company and that has
been largely ignored by almost every
government program trying to support
entrepreneurship in the world these are
the people who are forgotten employee
number 15
right and it's at this stage that you
see things like Lean Startup principles
and rapid prototyping it's also at this
stage where investor relations becomes a
major thing that often leads to a
company falling apart and you need to be
able to get to markets you need legal
and accounting infrastructure and so
forth at that stage to the exit stage is
also a critical part of the ecosystem
are there opportunities to go IPO to be
bought by a big firm and once you do is
there a flexible labor market so that
the people who are working your in your
company actually see being in your
company as a positive step in their
career including you yourself if you're
the entrepreneur in regards to the ideas
and knowledge side of things if a big
company buys your firm does that mean
that your idea has just been killed
sometimes big firms by smart startup
companies with that intention but a lot
of times I just don't do a very good job
of taking the idea on to its full
potential
and finally you know you need bankruptcy
law you need transparent accounting
principles and so forth
for the companies to be sustainable
after they've gone through that startup
and growth phase so what's going on in
Asia well everywhere in the world
companies start with friends and family
money I don't think that's anything
unique anywhere and it's hard to get
friends and family money in every part
of the world what's the real bottleneck
in most Asian economies our angel
investors who have startup company
experience Tim mentioned that very well
last week in Japan he said it's only
been in the last couple of years that
he's seen successful entrepreneurs turn
into angel investors up until that point
they were you know people who did
personal investing in start-up companies
where people who had a lot of money but
they didn't know the world of
entrepreneurship venture capital
investments are the first thing that
have really grown in Asia there are some
slowdowns there's a downright flood of
venture capital money in China right now
and yet you have to say that a lot of
the thinking of the venture capitalists
is not really entrepreneur positive and
it's bad enough here in the valley
people talk about the dark side a lot
but in an Asia what you typically get
are people who came from a financial
institution or a consulting background
and so they don't really have the
operational experience of running a
startup company and that makes them
rather limited in their decision making
when they're on your board of directors
you do see Silicon Valley influence in
Asia there are a lot of initiatives by
Silicon Valley investors a lot of local
investors look at their LinkedIn page
and you find out they got an MBA
from Stanford or from Wharton or from
Berkeley or somewhere the exit patterns
are really different as I mentioned in
the u.s. 90 percent of successful exits
are by acquisition in Asia is the flip
in Japan and in South Korea 85 to 90
percent of all exits are going to be by
IPO and the amount of money that's
raised in IPOs in Asia is much smaller
than the average deal size in the u.s.
now that's different in China China has
reached a point where the average IPO
size in China is very similar to the
average IPO size in the United States
but I haven't been able to look at what
percentage of shares of stock the
entrepreneur keeps in Asia if you keep
too much the company is still your own
company even though it's a public
company and that's kind of there's a
problem there so here's how a venture
capital has grown in China over the last
ten years this only went up through the
first half of 2018 but in the first half
of 2018 the amount of venture capital
investment in China actually exceeded
the amount of venture capital investment
in the United States now what happened
with the u.s. graph for the second half
of the year is that it bounced all the
way up to 130 billion dollars that's
more money invested in venture capital
even than was invested during the
dot-com boom of 1999 but I'm not sure
just how far China went but I think it
went to like 80 billion it may not have
exceeded this huge amount in the US but
you can see the rise of the red bars I
mean it's definitely on par with the
United States at this point but if you
look at the number of deals you see
something interesting now I could find
this this is not just China this is all
of Asia and Europe right so in terms of
the money raised we saw this similar
thing to what was shown in the previous
slide so a lot of this is China right
and in terms of the amount of venture
capital invested but in terms of the
number of deals
notice that the bars that the graph does
not slope
nearly as steeply up there are fewer
deals for a larger amount of money which
means that the average deal size is a
lot bigger in Asia now what's going on
the flip side of this is if you look at
the Silicon Valley statistics the amount
of angel funding in Silicon Valley last
year for the last four years has been
dropping dramatically bigger deals
people are moving to later stage deals
they get their money quicker and they
have less risk and they have developed
the financial kind of expert knowledge
to be able to do late stage investments
in a way that's very competitive so I
think in Asia as well you see the kind
of financial backgrounds of a lot of the
the venture capital investors so mega
rounds a round of funding that raised
more than 100 million dollars this is
worldwide statistics went up from about
50 in the year 2013 to 382 in the year
2018 there's another chart that I didn't
put into this presentation that shows
what percentage of funding is going into
seed and what percentage of funding is
going into Series A what procedure
funding is going into this giant you
know pre IPO stage and the percentage of
money going into seed and series a is
shrinking so that you're really if you
have a unicorn in the making you're in
great shape
but it's actually harder to get first
funding now than it was on the exit side
on the u.s. sure enough here's over the
last oh seven or eight years you can see
that the number of exits by strategic MA
MA and also by out for a distressed
company was even more than ten to one
right 711 exits by acquisition and
fifty-eight exits by IPO you also see
that the US companies raised about a
similar kind of ratio of money in the
acquisition as they did in the IPO the
IPOs for the number of IPOs raised a
little bit more money than was raised by
the acquisitions but when you look at
that same pattern in Asia you see much
more IPOs that raised almost minuscule
amounts of money so that's what I mean
by the small IPO size in Asia typically
leads to a company that's really not
strong enough to stand the pressures of
the public market and that's going to be
a dangerous thing over the long term now
venture capital and other come other
countries Tim talked a little bit about
venture capital in Japan he cited 2.5
billion for 2017 the estimates I've seen
for 2018 are 3.8 billion now right 130
billion in the United States and 3.8
billion in Japan which has about half
the population of the United States so
one big difference between the way VC
works in Japan and in the US visa
corporate venture capital makes is
participating in about 30 percent of all
the venture capital deals in the US
it's the flip in Japan it is involved in
at least 70% of all of the venture
capital deals in Japan but as Japanese
company after company creates venture
capital group's it's remarkable that
more than half of their investments are
going to outside Japan so the Japanese
companies are here they are sending
groups over to Israel every year and
they are looking around Europe they're
looking pretty much worldwide for good
investment opportunities Korea has an
even smaller venture capital South Korea
has an even smaller venture capital
industry what's really distinctive about
Korea is that the South Korean
government has decided to kick-start
this they've created something that
people I here call the mother fund and
basically the venture capitalist applies
to leverage the venture capitalists
investment with with additional company
from money from the government so
there's a three billion dollar fund in
existence now and they're planning to
increase it by nine billion kind of sort
of by this year but everybody says that
it's incredibly painful to try to use
its government money what do you expect
so I I think that this is something
where South Korea is still on the
emerging side you do see the big
companies being very active in M&A and
corporate venture capital but they are
not really
I didn't finish that sentence they're
not really able to benefit that much
from what the startup companies are
doing at least I haven't seen a major
big win I've seen a lot of good
interesting things we had a samsung's
innovation group was investing in a
smartlock company here and they were
doing really good business but it's not
like the next uber
anyway that's what's going on in those
two other countries if you look at
Southeast Asia you see a huge increase
in the number of deals if you look at
the amount of money it's an even sharper
increase and notice that more than half
of the deals are being done in Singapore
and Indonesia is a really coming up
there and strong number two so you're
seeing you know a rapid rise in venture
capital I'm seeing a lot of cross-border
investment in VC funds that are focused
on Southeast Asia GoldenGate ventures
has just raised a round of about a
hundred and fifty or 200 million with
funding from all sorts of life insurance
companies and other groups all around
Asia and so the you know it's often
coming one kind of an I thought an
interesting summation of what the
situation for venture capital in Asia is
is in this chart so this is the growth
in deal value and granted this a few
years old and this is the growth in deal
volume so Southeast Asia has very high
growth both in the number of deals and
in the value of the deals whereas China
and India are kind of right in the
middle the deal value is growing a lot
and deal volume is growing some and then
you have less growth in the advanced
economies because they're already so big
you know you really how much venture
capital can an economy take people flow
there are entrepreneurs everywhere even
in places where the tea rate is very low
the growth stage is the real problem
it's hard to get good people to come to
work for a startup company and part of
this is that the incentivization schemes
are not very sophisticated
in Asia entrepreneurs don't like to use
their hard-earned investment money to
pay high salaries and stock options are
still much less a part of the deal than
they are here and you're seeing some of
the big firms siphoning off good workers
I give a hard time to be 80 but I would
dare say that grab and line and these
companies down in Southeast Asia are
pulling in an awful lot of people who
could be in start-up companies otherwise
there's a huge social stigma and it's
not only the fear of failure I think
those charts that I showed from the gem
report really show that it's the
perception of a lack of opportunity
that's the real thing that's keeping
people away from the startup sector and
some countries have very sticky
employment relations Japan called it
lifetime employment right that is a
disincentive to going to work for a
startup company because the chances that
you will stay your entire career with
that same startup company are like close
to zero the entrepreneurs who stay with
their company after exit may not be the
best managers of a sustainable company
that's where you have to get away from
your original idea and figure out how to
keep growing the company even after your
first product idea is gone so that kind
of lack of mobility can be a problem
with idea and knowledge flow yeah all
over the region there are hundreds of
millions of dollars going into tech
transfer programs to get more IP out of
universities and research institutions
what they're not getting is business
knowledge that's a real lack in the
you know a problem in this whole
innovation system innovation is not just
the technology it really requires
business knowledge and in that regard
mentoring is not really so
well-developed
in Asia most university professors in
Asia make terrible mentors because
they're not willing to take a risk
because my status if I told you
something that could be at all incorrect
would just be horrible
right I mean I have to go out and kill
myself or something and I think that you
tend to have less confrontational board
meetings in Asia
how else did Carlos con keep doing all
the things that he was doing with the
Board of Directors and Nissan not paying
attention and you know it may be
difficult in Asian cultures because of
Confucian traditions of apprenticeship
the model for education in Asia is not
based on the same model we're using in
the West here we base education on
platonic dialogue I argue with you and
we both learn in Asia you imitate the
master which is a great way to
internalize what the master knows but
you don't talk about it
and so the because it's a violation of
faced considerations to say why you
screwed up a lot of times you don't have
the analysis of failure that's really
the strength of Silicon Valley Silicon
Valley doesn't allow failure Silicon
Valley analyzes it and recycles what can
be recycled very well so the startup
companies really do have a hard time
getting to market just about everywhere
except in China and I think it's going
to get harder in China as the big
companies become better more you know
established and the failure of open
innovation systems where the big
companies really don't know how
to cooperate with startups they tend to
think of outsourcing relationships and
they don't really understand the value
of working with people whose technology
is not perfect yet people whose business
idea may change next month that that
kind of you know flexibility is hard in
a big company anyway the companies here
in the valley are probably better than
anywhere else in the world at doing that
so there are robust systems to support
entrepreneurs in Asia throughout Asia
the attitudes and opportunities for
entrepreneurs reveal the way that the
ecosystems are developing there's a huge
amount of variety the heart of one of
the hardest things about giving this
talk is to lump Asia together when
there's so much difference from country
to country in Asia much more than there
are differences even between the EU
company the countries you still see some
ecosystem weaknesses that we've talked
about I think what's really noticeable
this year this is the mega Trent mega
deals and I'm not sure that unicorn
counting is really that good at past
time there's somewhere between 390 and
450 unicorns in the world about half of
them--are in the United States about a
hundred of them are in China there are
10 of them in Southeast Asia according
to one source that I saw and they're
expecting another ten within the next
five years in Southeast Asia there are
there is one in Japan used to be two but
the company went public so it shouldn't
be called a unicorn in there and what
I'm kind of concerned with is that
unicorn status allows you not
to get your company ready for the public
market it allows you to keep going on
this kind of quasi startup footing where
you don't have the excellent business
practices you don't have the
transparency that eventually you will
need if those relationships become too
sticky I'm kind of afraid that we might
be recreating the business groups in
Japan or South Korea right the Chabal in
South Korea or the chaotzu in Japan
because there will be a lot of
cross-shareholding of stock a lot of
long-term shareholding of stock that's
not going to go anywhere on the public
market so valuations the kind of
question become questionable this is a
topic that I think really bears watching
and I'm hoping to devote some more time
in the series to it and finally the
us-china friction is a real wild card I
think that we need good positive
presence Silicon Valley has depended on
world markets since about 1980 and so we
really need to have a good environment
for global knowledge we're going to be
involved in global competition so being
involved in global cooperation where we
can is a good thing and I'm really not
sure where this is going to play out
it's a lot deeper than trade problems it
has to do with national security issues
it does have to do with a particular
type of government industry
relationships that would not be possible
here
and so that's a wild card we need to
watch that for this year on that kind of
depressing note that's the end of my
prepared comments I we've got some time
for Question and Answer thank you very
much for your attention
you